[Music]
is
[Music]
lawmaker young hein made national
headlines on july 5th when she returned
back from a maternity leave with a
two-month-old child in a stroller
she was only the third lawmaker to give
birth during legislative term in south
korea
[Music]
[Music]
seeking to pass a bill that would allow
members of the national assembly to
enter a proceeding hall with their
children under 24 months old the current
law allows no person other than the
national assembly members government
delegates and relevant people necessary
for examining bills to have access to
any meeting place
the country's parent relief policy
includes 90 days of paid leave before or
after childbirth and fertility treatment
leave
on paper south korea's parental leave is
slightly longer than oecd average of 55
weeks
but the paid leave programs are not well
used in general in the country
oecd
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
experts say this also contributes to
south korea's record low birth rate
the number of birth per woman sank to
0.84 in 2020 the lowest in the world
a 2020 survey indicated that the
majority of working women experienced
some form of discrimination including
sexual harassment and wage
discrimination
[Music]
a mother of a three-year-old child says
she constantly had to fight gender
discrimination in a previous job
foreign bloomberg reached out to the
company but the company was unwilling to
provide a comment on her claims
on
to address this the ministry released a
four-year plan last year to expand
policy supporting women on career breaks
parent-to-leave child care services and
to promote the culture of gender
equality in the workplace
the government has also spent billions
to lift the low birth rate
but it admits more needs to be done
[Music]
and as in many other countries kobe 19
has had a disproportionate impact on
women in south korea widening the pay
gap
me south korean women also face the
largest pay gap of any industrialized
nations
foreign says she plans to propose more
bills reviewing the country's overall
care system that could benefit both men
and women in the workforce
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you